welcome guys it's been a little while
I've been low-key panicking about the
coronavirus that's coming up as I know a
lot of you have and normally I talk
about serious stuff this isn't a serious
video I understand coronavirus is a
deadly virus I'm not trying to make
light of the suffering I'm making light
of the fact that we have to live with it
we have to be at home we have to go
through this so while we're going
through it together if we can get a good
laugh out of it oh gosh it feels a
stupid explaining myself here
memes guys its memes while I tried to
stay sane inside I make videos is what I
do this is what I would be doing in my
free time anyway just looking at memes
so I'm gonna make a video about it I
don't know does that how to not get
coronavirus part one it's gone wrong
that time hey it's going on that time
right now avoid touching torn up with
your hands
effective method dude alright
coronavirus changing us how we watching
ESPN after they cancel it every other
sport
it's really like that right now isn't it
we don't have any sports left we have
nothing left about bowling because no
one goes there anyway this Carl Carl
Carl oh did that guy just touch his hand
coronavirus you got effectively reading
the paper ward were three never happened
and Australia finally stopped burning
garage fires all right me explaining to
my grandchildren how a guy eating bat
soup in China led to a toilet toilet
paper shortage to the United States
dude this is actually true I went to buy
my grocery store the other day to get
some like you know necessities and I
went to go get some buy some toilet
paper like like a regular amount guys
not like a crazy amount like we're just
like happened to be running low and
r.i.p boys this was the line outside of
my grocery store and immediately the the
toilet paper was out so that's actually
true toilet paper shortage barfi
everyone's just stocking up on toilet
paper right now it's insane I saw this
lady what are you doing how are you
gonna use all that toilet paper it's
ridiculous all right what's next
10:24 dead Chinese people one correct
too soon it says too soon yeah it
actually is too soon
kid hey mom when is this coronavirus
thing gonna be over mom just shut up and
eat your toilet paper hello darkness my
old friend
it's too much you guys have too much
toilet just need to get me some peel box
me some toilet paper boys corona virus
infects the whole world plague inc
players total organ failure oh no total
organ failure causes too much visibility
guys that's why you don't get it until
you have the whole world infected how it
feels waking up every morning in 2020
damage report oh man I don't even I
don't even check the news anymore it's
so sad me after hearing someone call for
my $8.00 round-trip flight to Italy it's
it's the risk/reward isn't it isn't it
you could get a really cheap flight you
could a super cheap flight but your roll
of the dice dude it's like Russian
Roulette but you get a trip anywhere you
want in the world for a really low price
airlines are going crazy right now who
would win the stock market or seizing
back well I think we have our answer
actually there
I think sneezing bat is clearly the
winner school's due to coronavirus on
all classes are gonna be online schools
maybe this is the solution we've been
looking for guys they can't shoot you if
you're all online school shooters right
now are super depressed everybody's home
I'm Chinese so I'm not being racist
normal people when they get sick in bed
this is gonna be so racist it's already
gonna be racist you've said it I'm
Chinese - no not being racist it's
probably gonna be racist Chinese people
when they get sick oh no no not on my
channel you guys are gonna bring this
racist stuff on my channel perspectives
your grandparents were called to war
you're being called to sit T on your
couch you can do this that's kind of
true right I mean this is like the first
big event of our generation like
worldwide catastrophe our job is to sit
on our couch like it's actually what
you're supposed to do to help everybody
that's
the World Health Organization has
declared that dogs cannot transmit
coronavirus and there's no need to let
quarantine dogs anymore who let the dog
stupid
that's stupid dude alright alright dad
the extinction of humanity millions of
gamers who now have not left the room
for years hey also millions of youtubers
have not left their rooms for years
coronavirus being an introvert right now
is a is a good thing man you're helping
out humanity just being yourself did
anyone bring any food you prep that's
what's happening you Preppers right now
to the lady who bought so much toilet
paper that's what's happening to her
right now
coronavirus shame on you shame on you
when boomers kill the earth but corona
virus kills boomers well well how the
turntables Austria bans gatherings of
more than 5 people during the corona
virus families with more than 5 people
one of yous got to go is it Demi NBA
players we're gonna play games without
fans in attendance WNBA players first
time beams guys I did not make them no
dad I'm watching a WNBA game after this
as penance for laughing at this hand
sanitiser company CEOs right now
coronavirus death count is this safe for
work
this is rough this is right hey I'm out
boys they said no no no that's terrible
that's horrible oh no coronavirus do we
must stop it the world's got to come
together and stop this virus this is
ridiculous
I shouldn't make fun of coronavirus I
don't know anything about it other than
if you get it you have this unbelievable
urge to go to the airport why do you
guys do that I guess you know I guess
like you know when you get sick you're
just like man I really really really
want to get on a packed tube with a
bunch of other people right now laughs
while we still can't uh yeah yeah that's
what this is all about laughing while we
still can
normal people with fever people with
coronavirus all across the land
searching far and wide who wash your
hands for 20 seconds the automatic sink
in the public bathroom best I can do is
1.5 why are all public bathroom
automatic sync's so bad you like put
your hands under it for two seconds just
[Music]
shh-shh-shh dude you manufacturers have
to stop penny pinching in the water bill
there when both 1820 and 1920 had
massive plague outbreaks the
anti-vaccine is a thing and it's the
year of the rat danger voice is that
true
I know 1920 had a where we thought what
was the 1920 plague what is going on
guys oh that was the Spanish flu okay
what was 1820 the first cholera epidemic
oh oh oh oh is the first cholera
epidemic dude oh we're in danger boys
danger zone
coronavirus canceled in New York because
of coronavirus is that it relied lied
coronavirus coronavirus cumference
coronavirus dude it's stopping
everything coronavirus has us all shut
down dude
we're all stuck at home bored you're
watching this because you're bored I'm
bored we're all bored because we have
nothing to do there's nothing to fight
like it's not like you can go join up in
the military right now and go fight the
coronavirus it's not a thing you just
have to sit at home and hope nobody
coughs on you and hope you don't coffin
anyone else Oh
public health avoid being crowds to
prevent the spread of the virus people
being terrified of the virus y'all need
to stop stocking up boys alright well I
think that's gonna be it thank you guys
so much for watching gonna be here all
week I'm gonna be here all week I'll be
here tomorrow for you guys to have
another I don't know what we're gonna do
tomorrow but we do something coronavirus
related just because I feel like I
already have so much anxiety about it
and I know a lot of you guys probably do
we're all sitting in our rooms bored so
we're gonna try something else we're
going to try doing a little coronavirus
stuff the point is not to be like you
guys know I'm not a health official okay
you know where to find real health
sources don't take my anything I say
seriously but we're just trying to keep
the light over here guys
you
[Music]